ok my name is Jerry Thomas I'm from the
Milwaukee School of Engineering and my
talk is my experiences on teaching
computational engineering to a variety
of students
about a year ago I had a conversation
with Steven about the possibility of
teaching a course on computational
engineering at msoe and I was faced
several challenges to do that first of
all ms we did not have a mathematical
license so that was one of the first
problems and I wasn't sure how to work
it into the curriculum that was another
problem and wasn't sure what kind of
book to use which was the third problem
so in rapid-fire succession I ended up
solving all these problems and I ended
up using a stevens book I should say
that one of the things I do as an
adjunct as I end up teaching a variety
of courses some in software engineering
some in computer engineering some an
electrical engineering and the advantage
of that was when we talked about having
the course in our department it sounded
like it would be a course it would
appeal to all three different
disciplines and the best choice seem to
be to target it for people who were
seniors and would use this course as one
of their required electives and so
that's what we ended up doing so I'm
going to go through and tell you a
little bit about some of my experiences
and teaching the course my personal
motivation for doing the course is that
some of you know for a long time I've
been working on it advanced decision
theory based on game theory and I was
hoping I would teach a course on that in
msoe and I thought this might be a
reasonable start for that and I also
thought that I might teach some other
courses all of which would be based upon
Mathematica so I'm go through and tell
you a little bit about that so I'll talk
about what I thought about computational
engineering a little bit about how
different people in these different
disciplines visualize data because it's
really quite different and some of the
simulations that seem to be effective
and also
I would love to talk about the stuff on
game theory all i can say is i just
finished the book it's the bookstore
downstairs so here's my plug so now i
don't have to talk about that right so
for my cursor again here so what about
the computational engineering course so
I had some opening questions it may be
hard to see yeah yeah but I means I have
to use my glasses because i can't see
what close up how about 200 right oops i
can go to 200 right
how about 200 ok your eyes get all the
way you can't see close nevermind i was
asked to talk alida discussion at
carthage this last summer about teaching
a course like that and i thought some
questions were kind of interesting which
i would share it's kind of an opening to
the course that I did teach because I
have different disciplines what is it
that the disciplines have in common why
does you know how do you teach two
different disciplines and of course in
today's age because I also teach
freshman and I find that the freshmen
that come in come from a variety of
backgrounds I mean even though you think
that they all have the same SATs or
whatever they're not really the same
what are the disciplines have in common
in terms of their language they use a
common mathematics or a common way of
visualizing do they do simulations and
can just a group I like this sort of
pick up Mathematica I mean I wasn't sure
whether that was going to be possible so
I I needed to have a definition of what
I thought computer engineering was may
not exactly coincide with what Steven
thanks but I think it's similar I see it
as a method of how do you analyze data
sets whether they're large data sets are
small data sets so it's a way of
thinking about data so that's one of the
things it's also a way of simulating if
you see a bunch of you know if you see
data you actually don't know what it
means so you have to have a model some
way some conceptual way of thinking
about it and you use the conceptual way
of thinking about it by creating some
kind of simulation so one of the things
the strength of a computational
engineering approach is how do I look at
the data large and small sets how do I
simulate large and small sets and then
how do I you bring the two together and
make a comparison to see whether I made
any progress this is the
we need to go down there a little bit
these are the course outcomes you know
in a university setting you have to say
at the end of this course what are
people supposed to get out of it right
so I wanted them to be first of all
confident in programming I should say
that I had tried an approach before I
had used without a license tried to
teach people mathematica at msoe and I
found that if i started at a fairly high
level the electrical engineers would
like stop paying attention in the the
software engineers who knew java said we
already know programming that's just
another programming language and they
stopped paying attention and the
community janiers said we don't even
want to hear about it so I knew what my
challenges were so and I couldn't get
him to be confident so one of my goals
this sim first goal was was non-trivial
and I really want to be to walk away
saying we know how to use this for the
rest of our life this is it they should
be able to create short program segments
or language segments they should have
some knowledge of some of the more
arcane parts of Mathematica just to see
if they could really pick it up and the
key thing for simulations is solvers so
you need to be familiar with all the
different kinds of solvers that are
there in Mathematica and the key thing
for visualizing are sort of plotters so
if you can get them to know the how do
you make plots how do you do simulation
how you do solvers your kind of there
okay
so I'm going to fast forward just in
case I run out of time I want to give
you the end story i mean i should say
that the people that I started with from
these three different disciplines had no
knowledge of Mathematica the electrical
engineers had no knowledge of
programming the software engineers had
no knowledge of simulations all the
univer graphs in the computer engineers
knew see and matlab the at the end i
asked them to each do a project in their
respective domain using Mathematica
using all the things that we had learned
this was one of the projects and the
person gave me a full note book
explaining what an L system was showing
me simplified examples of weeds building
it up from weeds and weeds it had colors
and colors that had branches branches
that had leaves at the end that were
still Brown and then branches at the end
like this which was a real tree and then
what would happen if you varied some of
the younger and make parameters so I was
really impressed and some of the other
projects at the end were some people
were interning at in industry they
applied the project to one of the
industry type problems some people were
working on seeing design they applied it
to their senior design problem the SES
as you might imagine applied it to
Pokemon but the point is they all did
their thing and while we're very happy
at the end so my approach was very
different having learned that
approaching it at the level that I
thought they were at was going to be a
total failure I said why you know the
thing about using Wolfram's book is this
written for people who are like high
school junior high school students right
and I'm not ashamed that's the way I
learned I learned I go find some very
simple book you know I will read
Prince I learn about literature so I
said let's use this book it's got so
many sections or chapters like 1 through
50 or say whatever it is it let's just
march through and every week we'll do
some number of chapters you can read it
anytime you want you can keep up it's so
simple you would be embarrassed not you
know to show up a classy you don't know
this stuff and so one of the first
things it did is it taught people about
lists and lists plotting and colors and
they could start doing simple things
with it about midway I should say msoe
is on the quarter system so three weeks
into it for weeks into it we have a
midterm or five weeks into we have a
midterm so i bought midterm this is the
kind of problem i was already giving
them i I talked to them about learning
sets training sets so I asked them you
know I says here's something in in the
wolfram help I just extract it right
then I said first of all I want you to
do your own training set with pictures
and identify people and then I gave him
a problem and I said a a couple of them
came up with it by themselves how about
if i give you even numbers and odd
numbers can you create a training set
that works and as far as i know you
can't yes Stephen actually just this
afternoon he doesn't know of how to do
that one either but why ok the why is
it's the heart it's a really bad set
except the answer is obvious to is even
force even five is odd right because
it's del Griffith you know exactly what
the answer is that's a good contact
center for this ok doing pictures works
in in the wolfram help thing because all
the real work has already been done you
give this to students and the first
thing they do is they try to do training
on those three pictures so what goes
wrong they're different sizes
they have different color spaces where's
the head okay is it over next to the
guys both hike or is that a is that part
of a face or there are people around
that have bow ties as part of their face
the reason the training sets work is you
have to go through a process and for
time I won't actually try to run it but
the process is you need to get the
pictures to have a size you need to get
rid of the color space so that you're
down to like a grayscale or something
and once you've done that all of a
sudden the training set works and I mean
you know that probably the students
didn't know that so when they were doing
the homework exercises they got it all
wrong and so then we would have this
discussion how come this doesn't work
okay and we were done then I will give
him the explanation I just did and
notice in doing this exercises look at
all of the technology from Wolfram stuff
they had to understand they're already
doing rules with the triple axe and the
transpose ax and you know they're having
to think through all of this this is
after five weeks I was very impressed
and that meant that my software
engineers my computer engineers they're
all on board now the different
disciplines focused on different things
like this was a picture that the
software engineers could really hone in
on computer engineers electrical
engineers were sort of there but had a
hard time keeping up
another thing for this the software
engineers is once you can already
boarded that's okay give them a list
this is American Airlines financial data
okay so they can it's now easy for them
to pull that off of the web and get a
time series plot but you know how to do
plots and but you can ask some
interesting questions which go way
beyond the simplicity of this example
for instance this is a jaggedy plot are
these things correlated in a causal
manner I mean that's kind of an
interesting question right because
normally we think is just statistical
things if I were to make a plot of the
time series against the time series the
correlation between adjacent points it
should just be quite noise right so real
simple thought provoking question to
them is what do you expect white noise
this is what you see it's not white
noise is it it has structure it
indicates that there are some causal
effects and if you thought about it well
stock markets actually do care about
what happened yesterday and what other
stocks are doing there are some cause it
affects things now how do i get the
electrical engineers computer engineers
on board gets software engineers they
like the beautiful pictures and the
visualization electrical engineers they
are heavily into simulations so this is
what this is the world they live in the
world they live in is have been dictated
by four years or three and a half years
of using multi-sim and tools and they
don't even think anymore they just use
the tools so if you say what's the
behavior of an electrical circuit that
then they go well you know
I go to multi-sim and I draw these
pieces in there and I push start and if
they get an answer they don't actually
know whether the answer right or wrong
they just know but I press Start and I
got the stuff so since I've taught those
courses I know what their problem is
when I give them homework assignments
and say okay calculate for me by hand on
a midterm what are the voltages at each
point they get it all wrong so they
don't have a simple way to do the
algebra it's the problem of algebra and
getting unit straight you know i will
ask them ok g here's if I got a 1 farad
capacitor and it's right here and they
go ok really one fair head so I said ok
if I have a plate you know one
millimeter apart from another plate how
big is the place anybody know some miles
or something big then I said I just read
in a spec sheet that they're selling you
know these cars that drive along with
big boom boxes they have one farad
capacitors is that true yes it is true
but that's what thinking is all about
right then you say ok so why is it true
well you still have the problem of the
spacing but you can make it really
complicated and fill the volume in a
different way and you could put a
dielectric in there that really improves
the capacitance and you can do it and
someday you know 10 years from now 50
years from now we'll use 10 farad
capacitors as batteries so they're just
storage tanks so here's the way they
normally solve problems set up a problem
in steady state it's algebra have
somebody do the arithmetic that the
units for them so that one fair at is
going to get interpreted correctly
do all of that do a solver right so you
just have to solve you know physics an
electrical engineer very simple you have
a couple of wads conservation of energy
conservation of charge you put it into
some vernacular and it will give you the
solution in boys mathematica does that
pretty nicely and for my electrical
engineering students they want to do
problems like this different problem
saying picture saying multi-sim
different button on multi-sim this time
instead of having something simple you
go why don't you let this capacitor he
have some voltage or some charge on it
and what happens in time so how does it
come to steady state well a lot of them
don't even know what button to push I'd
multi-sim but again set up same setup
same units visualization now is more
showing the the transient effects die
out having a conversation to them about
what a transient effects what's the time
period of transient affects all of these
become very very important for the
learning of the student now I could I
tried to intersperse en things that were
outside their experiences now for
electrical engineers I won't go through
that but I did more complicated
visualizations they know about
electromagnetic fields magnetic field so
I give them here's a little line so long
it's charged what does the field look
like okay here's a magnet as a shape
what does the field look like and if i
have the field can i rotate the thing
around and do this all of the things
that you know how to do and that was
another learning tool I brought stuff in
for my own research as you guys don't
know this you know nothing about game
theory and finances and stuff like that
so why don't we do some game theory
problems okay so we'll spend a day
learning what is a game theory will
learn about matrices min max theorems
some neat ways to tie that stuff
together put it together make take a
problem like the kids rock scissor paper
problem try that so that's kind of cool
and when you're all done you can even
make it time-dependent and do some
simulations I just intersperse these
things like throughout the quarter and
just mention them sort of like I am now
the purpose of my course however was I
wanted to remember why outcomes to get
him to think so let me talk it about the
end game what did we learn how am i
doing on time by the way oh I'm right on
time right okay one of the successes was
using Wolfram's textbook I mean not
there aren't other text books out there
potentially the PERT the success was the
textbook was so simple that they
couldn't object and yet it carried them
through to very quickly get to advanced
subjects and they weren't embarrassed
about it I wasn't embarrassed about it
we just said okay this is what it does
and once they learned how to apply it
they could do G we did plot net wordless
black now we're doing plot we did solve
now we're doing d solve and i should say
when I would look at a group of students
like electrical engineers I'd say you
guys have to take because I'm in a bit
accreditor you guys have to take
differential equations right right how
many of you have taken a course in
differential equation everybody's hand
goes up how many know remember anything
at all about them come on somebody
raised their hand
can somebody even give me the name of a
differential equation how about y prime
equals y ki that okay what couldn't
think through that but using solve and
just say just introducing differential
equations in Mathematica say I'm not
going to ask you to differentiate it
integrated multiply had divided anything
just solve it and plot it and tell me
you know if you're very inspir immured
or what happens and start thinking about
it and what's what does this do that
they could do so the textbook helped i
think the mathematica was a really good
tool to get them to think because i try
to challenge them with problems that
were not in their discipline necessarily
and because there were three different
disciplines when i was talking to this
group these two groups didn't know that
to start with so we would do for the
software engineers a graph theory
problem bringing up a geomap like
talking about in the last section here's
a place in Europe here's another place
find the shortest path between the two
the software engineers would say
normally we would solve that with graph
theory using Java and they would come
back in a couple of months and say okay
we've solved it okay couple of weeks but
they wouldn't come back right away okay
this one gave them the ability to do it
right away the soft the computer
engineers electrical engineers didn't
know graph theory they didn't know that
the nearest PF stopped and they didn't
know the bellman-ford and they didn't
know any of that stuff so they could get
there also software engineers did not
know simulations but they learn
simulations and the electrical engineers
loosen em and say yeah this is what you
do this is what you do this equation so
they got it so this was helpful I did
learn there is a value for engineers on
the tools that they already have and you
can't replace that one of the problems
has been people trying to go into
schools like ems so Ian say get rid of
matlab
mathematik is better no look they're
tools multi7 java they're not for
thinking their engineering tools they're
simply cut and dry ways of getting the
answer and they're going to go into
industry where those tools are used they
need to be proficient in those those
there's nothing wrong with that but I
worked at a startup I wouldn't hire him
unless I could think they could think so
in addition to those tools they need a
mathematic and they need a way to get
out of that box and say okay you got a
one farad capacitor with no special
things and you gave that to me as an
answer you come on the student projects
were the way I saw that I saw them go
into their discipline and go deep into
what they knew and I saw their thinking
like the the L system that was like out
of the blue I had asked them a question
draw for me a serpent's key triangle the
princely dragon okay and a couple of and
some fractals and then they went away
under test and they went away and they
got that so I would he ask them no
here's a flag give me the three closest
flags to this Brazilian flag okay so i
picked this one whatever it is now i
just give it to you you don't know where
it's from now tell me where that flag is
from okay that was on the final it and
most of them tatted final grades were
actually pretty good so I think
Mathematica in the end was my impression
from talking to students is that you
might ask me was this of any good to you
was this of help gonna use this later in
life and they said yeah we're going to
use this this is really you know they
were kind of surprised I had some
students who I one of the things about
teaching in different courses different
disciplines as I had many of these
students in other courses so and I knew
some of them were really pretty bright
in some of them were you know not as
quick doesn't mean they were bright it
just means like on a test this guy
finishes in half an hour the skate
finishes in two they both get to the end
even with their kind of a spread I got
you know everybody's from that big
spread the very quick ones and the ones
that were not so quick enjoyed it so
basically I was very happy so I will it
take this opportunity to stop and thank
you for your very polite attention and
take any questions if I have time
[Applause]